it's great to be joined in studio today
by Richard Stallman who is founder and
leader of the free software movement you
can learn more about this at gun org
that's G and you org you're a very
colorful character and in my research of
you I came across of so many things that
I want to talk about but let's start
with maybe what you're most known for
which is being involved in the free
software movement I know that you don't
like when people sometimes incorrectly
conflate canoe and Linux we're talking
about two different things so let's just
start there talk to us about what is
ganene has Linux relate to that
okay well the standard question is
what's new right and the standard answer
is gnu's not Unix
right because that's what ghanoush
stands for it's a recursive acronym it
stands for good news not Unix this is
programmers humor but it has a serious
meaning of course Anu is the name of the
operating system whose development I
launched in January 1984 and I decided
to make it similar to that is you use it
the same as Unix an existing operating
system but the special thing about new
was it would be entirely free software
entirely freedom respecting software the
users would have full control over
everything in it whereas with
proprietary systems like UNIX or Windows
or Mac Oz or stuff in those mobile
devices right those those are not free
software the users do not control them a
company controls those programs and the
programs control the users and is that
sort of what underlies your advocacy for
free software this is opposition to
companies big corporations typically
matter whether they're big or small okay
the point is we should control the
programs we use and not vice versa so
every program is either free or
proprietary if it's free
that means the users control the program
they control the program separately and
they control it collectively
the same time both kinds of control are
there now today there are many more
examples of the proprietary debate
easily I didn't finish what I was saying
oh I'm sorry I do pause I speak in
paragraphs sometimes so the point is
that's free software but if the users
don't control the program then instead
the program controls the users and the
proprietor some company typically
controls the program so that program is
in instrument which gives the proprietor
power over users it's a tool to
subjugate people with that's the
injustice that we are trying to put an
end to first step we escape from it
ourselves I don't use any proprietary
software I won't tolerate it on this
computer here you know this is has only
free software in it we've worked decades
to make it possible you can actually buy
a computer pretty much like this that
comes with free software already
installed what computer is that talk
this especially for people who might
only be with this is a ThinkPad X 60s
IBM well it was Lenovo but the point is
they nowadays they're selling a somewhat
newer model in which they've installed
free software the point is you don't
even have to install the system yourself
you don't have to be a wizard to use
free software but the point is non-free
software is an injustice so we've got to
get rid of it and nowadays the
proprietors intentionally put malicious
functionalities into their proprietary
software companies you heard of such as
Microsoft Apple Amazon Adobe they put
malicious functionalities in they put in
backdoors meaning they can remotely
control it whether you like it or not
they put in surveillance functionalities
but snoop on the user's and send
information they have digital
restrictions management DRM which is
which means it's designed to refuse to
do
the things you want with the data that
you get and these are all in Justices
now let me before we get too far off
because I want to keep on one area of
this laptop that you pointed out I
believe Intel is on the list of
companies whose products you don't use
correct what analysts are here this is a
sum this machine was actually made
something like eight years ago the
latest Intel processors are designed
with a backdoor that means it can be
remotely controlled by Intel or any
government that can compel Intel's
cooperation and we don't know what all
those government's are you must not
trust the latest Intel processors and if
you want more information look at
Stallman org slash Intel dot html' I
think yeah we're going to get to that in
more limpa the point is it's malicious
hardware we don't know any way to fix
that we can only use older processors at
the level you have here yes okay however
people are raising funds to design a new
computer that will be manufactured
specifically for free software it has a
non Intel processor but not AMD either
their newest processors are no good
either but the point is we keep
advancing so now you can buy a
reconditioned computer with only free
software in it right but if that project
gets funding and succeeds you'll be able
to buy a newly made laptop designed for
free software now why just software and
I guess what I mean is this any computer
you could have free software and a
processor you could have free hardware
designs well I get or not my question
buddy why can't make your own processor
sure but I guess my question was that's
sort of where I was getting at right
which is if you have a video card it
presumably has proprietary firmware if
not soft well so where do you draw the
line I guess we draw the line between
software that comes embedded and that
people are
going to change and software at the
installed levels of the system right
because in a physical piece of hardware
there may be embedded software but we
can't even tell us there yeah
and that certainly people don't users
don't consider changing you know every
keyboard has embedded software every
disk has embedded software the processor
may have embedded software but the
camera if there is one has embedded
software I'm guessing you would never
have a laptop with a built-in camera
right well I'd probably tape it over
yeah I have when there I've used such a
laptop I've taped it over but that's a
different issue if you've got free
software you can be sure it's not turned
on with a proprietary program you can't
trust the developer every proprietary
program gives you zero security against
its own proprietor the only way that you
can have security against the people who
develop the software is if they don't
have ultimate control in other words if
it's free software we contributors to
free software we don't have ultimate
control we can't make users accept sight
unseen whatever we've done the users can
all see if they look what we've done
they can compare versions they can check
it and if they don't like what we've
done they can change it this is what it
means to say the users have ultimate
control now the power that proprietary
developers have well power corrupts and
they have total power over those users
and they know it and they are thoroughly
corrupt I would say that putting in
malicious functionalities is corruption
and if you want to see the full story
about the malicious functionalities we
know of look at gönül org slash
proprietary there dozens of examples
there each one with a reference in the
press why do you think that this because
that what you're telling us about should
be of concern on a day to day basis to
many more people than I believe it is a
concern for do you think it's people
have lives that they're living and they
don't necessarily have the time to look
into that detail is it what do you think
it is
but also you've got to realize that the
media when they cover technology are
funded by advertising by the same
company and these companies don't
encourage the media to consider these
questions if you look at product reviews
you will see that they don't talk about
the question of the license of the
program to what extent do the users
control it how can they trust it right
and I once saw a comparison review of a
new software package that I had written
with various proprietary programs that
did a similar job and the review
considered only practical dimensions it
didn't consider the ethical dimension of
the freedom dimension at all so I wrote
a letter to the editor afterwards
pointing out that this most important
point of all was omitted what obligation
was that I don't remember this was in
1990 but in other words they were
talking about features functionality
speed itself and then ignored the
underlying what you ignored the most
important thing because they never
talked about that right in 1998 the free
software movement was hit by a
co-optation campaign designed to
separate our software from our
philosophy of freedom right that
campaign goes by the name open-source
now the reason you've heard that term so
much is that a lot of companies
preferred to talk about open source and
they wanted the media to talk about open
source precisely because that didn't
rock the boat it didn't criticize their
proprietary software didn't call it in
injustice so the companies have put
their their weight behind the use of the
superficial term that doesn't raise
ethical issues it's very PR friendly to
say something is open-source right right
and they've talked about our work in
connection with their slogan so much
that most people think that's what I
stand for I refuse to go normally to any
event that uses the term open source
because I don't want to feed that error
well I want to talk about that yeah
pause briefly if we can because we I
just want to take a short break and then
we're going to talk about more I'm here
with Richard Stallman in studio you can
learn more at GNU org we're still with
Richard Stallman here in our Boston
studio he is the founder and leader of
the free software movement you can learn
more at GNU org before we move on to
some other topics Richard you were going
to sort of wrap us up on this idea of
the confusion sometimes between Ganu and
Linux yes
in 1992 the new system was almost
complete one component was missing and
then mr. Torvalds released a program
called Linux which did that job so Linux
filled the last gap in the new system
but lots of people got confused and they
thought that the whole combination was
this one piece Linux so if people say
that they're using Linux they're
actually using GNU with Linux right and
I think that that is a confusion that is
very common especially if you look on
the internet ok you don't use air B&B
Amazon and track Apple ebooks Eventbrite
Evernote Facebook Google Intel LinkedIn
meetup microsoft netflix pay toilets
skype spotify theater and neighbor for
different reasons ok so question one is
is there any underlying for no-no
between all of these there are different
reasons I can't talk about any one of
them several of those companies I refuse
to use because they require users to
identify themselves ok that's why I
won't take am track I take the bus I pay
cash I don't show an ID I will have
credit cards I have one which I use only
for airlines and if I were going to rent
a car ok and the reason for those
exceptions is they make you identify
yourself anyway so I wouldn't accomplish
anything by paying cash
but the point and you shouldn't have to
identify yourself for a domestic flight
it's wrong to track people well you know
why I'm going to let me let's explore
that a little bit in order to go when
you go through TSA they do check an ID
it allows you look for a domestic flight
you shouldn't have to be so you're
against that yes ok uh but
I can't really find an alternative to
flying it's tough but I can find an
alternative to Amtrak yeah
there's absolutely no reason to make
people identify themselves same for uber
I also call it goober because it pays
drivers peanuts right but my main reason
for absolutely refusing it is I won't
say who I am and it requires people to
run a non free app to book a ride I
won't run the non free app and I also
won't tell who I am
I'll use an ordinary taxi you don't have
to say who you are for those that's true
and it's the same thing for many of
those other companies but not all and by
the way I do occasionally use the Google
search engine but I don't identify
myself I connect through tor and I block
the JavaScript code from the site so
that Google can't effectively track me a
lot of other things in my browser also
to prevent tracking along those lines
something that I found interesting and
I'm curious to get your feedback on is
that you're big on Pepsi over coca-cola
and you cite these deaths that took
place in Colombia related to coca-cola
not particularly I'm not for Pepsi
you're against coke imal artisinal
coca-cola Baron ouch coca-cola company
not just coca-cola the product but
anything that company makes and in many
countries you have to drink bottled
water from health resource but I make
sure it's not from coca-cola company
it's not that I think that their water
is any less safe than any other bottled
water but I participate in that boycott
so here's my question and here's where
we refused of working with the
paramilitaries to murder union
organizers and their families along
Lumbee ad in Guatemala right my question
is this
there's a sort of analogy that one could
make between the concept of proprietary
software and the concept of Pepsi's
proprietary recipe for their
directionally no in what sense isn't it
you've got the analogy wrong excellently
and now the
right analogy is between a recipe and a
program hmm just as a program produces
output the recipe produces output which
is food or in this case a drink ah but I
don't reject output made from
proprietary programs what I refuse is to
do my computing by running proprietary
programs now what would be the cooking
analogy of that was a human cook there
is none basically you can't give a human
cook a recipe to use that there won't
know correct in order to make a make a
recipe you have to know know what it is
you're aware of what you're doing or and
not only that you'll find it cooks will
share recipes what I want to say I think
the method is sort of romantic this note
but it's not it's they treat the recipes
as free for the same reasons you should
be free to redistribute the software you
have you should be free to change it and
cooks to change recipes and cooks even
occasionally write down their changes on
a copy of the recipe and and that to a
friend
some easy are the they're free to do it
when they want to do it they're not
required to in the same way that a
software company Kudo no no no sorry
you've got it wrong
the point is that every user of a
program should be free to do these
things and that's the definition of free
software freedom zero freedom to run the
program as you wish freedom one freedom
to study the source code of the program
and change it to function the way you
wish freedom to the freedom to make
exact copies and give or sell them to
others when you wish freedom free the
freedom to make copies of your modified
versions and give or sell them to others
when you wish these four freedoms define
free software and you'll note that when
cooks do those things with recipes
they're assuming the same four freedoms
with their recipes and recipes should be
free tour but the point is recipes don't
have a distinction between source code
and executable there are no compiled
recipes because recipes are executed by
human beings not by computers surely
it's not that being robots yeah if you
had cooking robots somebody would start
selling or maybe just giving away its
is bad proprietary recipes where you're
not allowed to know what the steps are
only the roller block from sharing the
recipe this would be the same evil as a
proprietary program and I would fight
against it in the same way but I don't
mind that some food was cooked using a
proprietor a private recipe just as I
won't reject something that was made by
a computer just because someone else was
running a proprietary program I don't
boycott companies because they
internally use Windows I'm just sorry
for them ok are the ones who are losing
freedom if they're running Windows or
Mac us or any proprietary program yeah I
would say to them I hope you free
yourself you do deserve to control your
own computing right but I won't boycott
them because they lost their freedom and
just I refuse the non-free software
myself and I won't lead anyone else to
use it because then I'd be leading that
person to lose freedom are there areas
of life that are challenging because of
the number of companies and their
services that you don't use well there
are some meetings that are difficult for
me to go to because they're set up such
that you have to use Eventbrite to
register and I can't talk to Eventbrite
that requires non free JavaScript code
which I refused to run but aside from
that a company has no business knowing
who's going to that meeting sure no only
one is I'm not anymore that way the day
to day life I mean as an example for our
audience like norm the reason you know
lower is just to tell our audience the
reason you're here we do all of our
interviews via Skype video but you don't
use Skype we were fortunate enough that
because you're here at MIT you were able
to come here but there are ways in which
you're certainly altering your day to
day as a relative these I don't do video
calls day to day but there is there I do
have a way to do them with free software
I don't know if your setup user it
didn't work with our says here's why I
absolutely refuse to use Skype
if I'm using Skype I'm talking with
someone else that's using Skype right
and I'm pressuring someone else to use
Skype and
that's wrong you see if you were using
Skype by yourself right
then you'd be the victim if you did that
once in a while I wouldn't say shame on
you yeah but if you're using Skype with
somebody else and you're causing someone
else to use Skype yeah you're doing
something wrong to that person
not only that you're part of the social
pressure that pushes people to use Skype
you really need to ethically use it's
incumbent on you to set it up so that
you're not urging people to you Skype
anymore mm-hmm now in our particular
case you would not have been urging
anyone to use Skype how did you
participate in that interview because we
were the ones who already had Skype I
know but I would be I would be part of
the reason why you keep using it it was
my duty to say no yeah so that you would
look for another way right so that I
wouldn't be complicit in keeping Skype
in its position of power and the last
year you are well Here I am good yeah we
found another way so when it comes to
the speaking that you do and the travel
that you do etc is your focus continuing
to be free software or do you also delve
into some of these other issues with the
companies etc what's your main advocacy
right now it's free software and privacy
okay and the way we protect people's
privacy is by not collecting data about
people data once accumulated will be
misused there are four ways the database
can be misused by the organization that
collected it that organization is very
likely to try to misuse it they sell the
data to a data broker or mistreat people
oh but it can also be misused by rogue
employees and this happened with uber by
the way they figured out who was having
a one-night stand right from their data
of who went weird and it can be misused
by thieves crackers that break the
security and take the data that's very
common and it can be misused by Big
Brother the surveillance state
which of course with the troll as
president is going to be inclined to
mistreat people for private reasons of
the troll I'm shocked you didn't vote
Trump so yeah I had you pegged as a
Trump guy when we met no I'm a Sandridge
support now I'm kidding I voted for Jill
Stein yeah do you see any way back in
the sense that increasingly society runs
on exactly the type of software you're
protesting we have to refuse to use it
we have to organize and say stop them
from collecting that data by the way I
have a charley card which I use to pay
for subways and buses so do I I only put
money in as cash and every so often I
get a new one so that the amount of
effective surveillance they can do with
it is limited limited to the cameras and
the tea stations and unblocked replicas
I don't think they're set up to
recognize faces very money I know that
oh I was in fact I was at the MBTA
control center recently for a program
I'm part of with the anti-defamation
league and it's very advanced but I saw
no indication by betaf point is we have
to have laws that won't allow them to do
facial recognition nobody should be
allowed to do systematic facial
recognition with cameras pointed at
public places except under a specific
court order identifying a particular
place in a particular period of time for
we need laws to stop the collection of
data which is a threat to dissidents and
whistleblowers you see democracy
requires whistleblowers heroes like
Snowden because they tell us what the
government's really doing you see
Snowden is a hero absolutely interesting
we had time I would call for three
cheers for him if we had an audience do
you distinguish between what Snowden did
and what Chelsea Manning did in the
seminal hero to in the sense that
specifically in the sense that Chelsea
Manning exposed actions that were crimes
under current law and while Edward
Snowden exposed behaviors that I agree
with you in terms of surveillance were
not useful worse by statute legal
doesn't matter doesn't matter because
they're a threat to democracy
they're a threat to our society to our
freedom so Snowden was a hero and by the
way some of them were illegal because
you know that the NSA was making a
monkey out of the FISA Court the FISA
Court could not effectively supervise
what the NSA and FBI are do i am doing i
agree with appointed by the letter of it
was not doesn't matter well I'm not sure
of that it was a rubber stamp exactly
yes which means the law is being ignored
but you know justice goes beyond obeying
laws and we need to know what the state
is doing to us and Snowden told us
Snowden is a great hero Snowden deserves
a medal and deserves to be put in charge
of the NSA Wow but the point is that
when you have a war on whistleblowers
going on and that's what Obama started
yeah how can you have whistleblowers how
can whistleblowers be safe if the
government always knows who goes we're
at who talks with whom it's very hard to
be a whistleblower so it's hard to have
democracy if we don't know what the
government's doing we can't decide what
did you do so the amount of surveillance
we have now in the US and many other
countries puts democracy in danger it's
more surveillance than existed in the
former Soviet Union we must push the
level of surveillance down to the point
where whistleblowers and dissidents are
safe what the reason why I don't have a
mobile phone yeah is that whenever
they're on their movements are tracked
and every mobile phone there may be a
few rare exceptions has a universal
backdoor that can be remotely activated
to convert it into a full time listening
device that listens all the time and
transmits all conversations through the
phone network to whoever it is and once
that once that change is made you can't
really switch it off either it pretends
to switch off but it's really still
running so I call them Stalin's dream
fortunately I found these things out
before I had one I considered getting
one but when I found these things about
it I decided it's my duty as a citizen
not to tolerate them so I don't I don't
have one I do
use mobile phones I use lots of
different mobile phones many of them
only once you had a burner no it's
somebody else's mobile Flagg answer I
say could you make a call for me or
scented text for me yeah this way big
brother doesn't generally know it's me
the point is that oh by the way anyone
can track you with the mobile phone
because there are bugs in the
communication protocol between mobile
phone systems which is called signaling
system 7 I believe I did not know that
so that anyone can pretend to be another
mobile phone network and talk to yours
and say where has this phone been for
the past 6 months or a year or whatever
what calls has it made and received what
text has it made and receive what were
the contents of those texts all that
information is available to anyone
willing to perhaps break some laws as
well as the big brother who doesn't have
to break laws is probably collecting all
of that data massively every week or
every day or every five minutes
so the point is it is surveillance so
extreme that most people don't imagine
it and if we want to have democracy
again we've got to stop it a true
cautionary tale from Richard Stallman
not about the future but about right now
I think it's very up you can learn more
at GNU org so great having you in or any
of these files about companies that I
suggest not using or avoiding in certain
ways those are in my personal website
Stallman dot org yes I did extensive
reading of that website and I recommend
it to everybody in our audience thank
you thank you